[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas un informe de la
comisión internacional para las personas
desaparecidas reveló que más de 15.000
de ellas entre militares y civiles
ucranianos se encuentran desaparecidos
desde el comienzo de la Guerra el pasado
24 de febrero la organización para las
libertades civiles ganadora del premio
Nobel de paz se esfuerza por tratar de
seguir el destino de estas personas
hasta el momento tiene más de 770 casos
confirmados sin embargo en medio de una
guerra que no da tregua se estima que
esta cifra puede ser inmensamente mayor
informe de Catalina Gómez Ángel
el invierno ha regresado a la población
de orane y con él La pesadilla para
larisa que después de ocho meses la
única noticia que tiene de su hijo
Alexander es esta carta recibida por
intermediación de la Cruz Roja
Internacional en la que solo dice que
está vivo y saludable pensamos que podía
estar en belarus buscando a su hermano
detenido con él cuando recibimos esta
carta supimos que él estaba vivo esta
población campesina al norte de kiev
estuvo en control ruso hasta el 26 de
Marzo cuando sus fuerzas se retiraron
del norte de Ucrania ese mismo día
Alexander Fue capturado junto con su
hermano menor
al pequeño lo enviaron a un orfanato en
velarúso porque no sabían Qué hacer con
él y cuando logré traerlo de vuelta a
Ucrania nos contó que pensaba que su
hermano tenía las costillas rotas
771 civiles están oficialmente
desaparecidos desde el 24 de febrero se
sabe que al menos 479 están en prisión
en los meses de calor me sentí mejor
pero ahora vuelven mis miedos qué hacer
aquí puede ver que esta coyuntura se
curó por su cuenta los fragmentos no
fueron sacados
Natalia hace parte del equipo del centro
por las libertades civiles esfuerzan su
trabajo en desaparecidos no militares
que por lo general no aparecen en la
lista de prisioneros que Rusia presenta
para intercambiar
estoy más segura que la mayor parte de
esta gente está en lugares de captura y
otra parte están los territorios
ocupados en Ucrania eso primero lo
segundo lo que más temo ahora mismo es
el invierno y sabemos en qué condiciones
Vive esta gente Hoy es un día en el que
el esfuerzo de ocho meses de búsqueda ha
dado sus frutos aunque con un final muy
triste para la familia ludmila
lo último que supieron de ella es que
quedó herida el 24 de marzo en bucha
bajo el control ruso para los familiares
es un gran alivio poder decir adiós y
saber qué fue enterrada bajo las
tradiciones ucranianas es muy importante
pero el dolor de esta familia no termina
el marido de ludmila Igor de 62 años
también es uno de los prisioneros
civiles en las cárceles rusas
en Ecuador la corte constitucional
suspendió temporalmente los requisitos
para acceder a un aborto en Casos de
violación que exigía la presentación de
una denuncia una declaración juramentada
o un examen médico certificado por lo
que ahora toda mujer podrá acceder a la
interrupción del embarazo mientras la
corte resuelve una acción de protección
interpuesta por grupos feministas a un
año de su entrada en vigencia activistas
a favor y en contra del aborto coinciden
en que el texto legal se ha convertido
en un privilegio social que desampara a
la mujer por ello demandan la
declaratoria de inconstitucionalidad o
derogatoria de la ley historia de
nuestro corresponsal Gustavo Ortega
venga de María por favor Pase Ana Vera
integrante del colectivo proaborto Sur
cuna escucha el reclamo de una madre que
busca apoyo para su hija de 13 años que
fue violada
entiéndame que es una niña y tampoco
tengo esta menor conforme a la lista de
113 niñas y adolescentes que son madres
cada día en Ecuador según el Instituto
Nacional de estadística un número
alarmante que inquieta a las ongs
nosotras con sentencia acompañamos
veintidós casos más o menos de mujeres
niñas sobre todo que necesitaban acceder
a un aborto por violación y después de
que se expedido la ley el Ministerio ha
reportado que solamente se han hecho
ocho abortos por causar violación
ley a la que no quiso someterse esta
otra mujer quien asiste a su médico de
confianza
750 abortos médicos Se realizaron en
Ecuador durante el año 2021 según la
Fuente oficial este médico cuestionó el
estado por no considerar la salud de
manera integral las consecuencias
físicas mentales y psicológicas de un
embarazo no deseado el aborto Debería
ser legal
y regulado eso científicamente ya sea
comprobado que no aumenta a los la tasa
de abortos Amparo Medina ex activista
proaborto no apoya esta postura después
de cambiar su manera de pensar Busca
persuadir a las mujeres de abortar
ofreciendo preparación para el parto
alimentación atención médica psicológica
y legal gratuita para ella la ley no
Resuelve los niveles de pobreza
desnutrición y desempleo a las que se
ven expuestas algunas jóvenes que
deciden interrumpir su embarazo
es darles las posibilidades para que
ellas puedan emprender puedan también
tener recursos apoyarles en el área
laboral en el área de emprendimientos
personales en el año 2021 nacieron en
Ecuador
41.295 niños de madres de 10 a 19 años
de edad según la Fuente oficial
457 madres tenían menos de 14 años para
las activistas la ley debe ser declarada
inconstitucional por no cumplir con los
parámetros internacionales de Derechos
Humanos por lo que se espera otra lucha
para abrir el camino hacia un nuevo
texto legal en Brasil hay cerca de un
millón de personas que viven con VIH el
77% de ellas Sigue un tratamiento con
antirretrovirales en el pasado Brasil
fue una referencia en la lucha contra
esta enfermedad en América Latina sin
embargo los recortes realizados durante
el gobierno de Jair bolsonaro han
reducido drásticamente las campañas de
prevención especialmente aquellas
dirigidas a la comunidad lgbtiq más y la
cantidad de medicamentos distribuidos
por el servicio de salud la consecuencia
es que cada hora hay cinco nuevos
contagios de VIH en el país Valeria
sakone y faniiroteo tienen la historia
Buenas tardes con Don gratuito querido y
el test ya lo has hecho quieres hacerlo
es un joven de 26 años que convive con
el VIH desde su nacimiento hoy es
activista en la principal ong de Río de
Janeiro
mis padres no hablan mucho sobre esta
cuestión lo que yo escuchaba en la calle
y en la escuela era Siempre sobre el
sida
y siempre de una forma muy pesada una
forma que yo considero equivocada
hoy se vino coordina un grupo de
voluntarios que realizan pruebas
diagnósticas en la calle de forma
gratuita el resultado sale en tan solo
15 minutos
en privado Sabinos se encarga de
comunicarlo
salió bien gracias a Dios chao
durante su mandato paralizó 12 programas
de prevención del Sida y cortó la
entrega de 615 millones de dólares
destinados a la compra de medicamentos
además en la última década el perfil
racial de esta enfermedad ha cambiado en
la actualidad el 62% de los fallecidos
Son afrodescendientes
creo que eso acontece principalmente por
la cuestión del racismo estructural
nos miran como si fuésemos personas
peligrosas criminales especialmente en
los centros
A falta de campañas efectivas los
contagios entre los jóvenes aumentaron
un
50%, se trata de un claro retroceso
según el portavoz de esta ong Aquí está
la cuestión del VIH una gran
preocupación porque sabemos que la falta
de continuidad en el tratamiento lleva
el Punto de partida
[Música]
hay que hacer todo en otro esquema para
que el paciente consiga la inmunidad y
el virus no se
repliquemos
la esperanza de este colectivo es que el
nuevo gobierno de Lula retome la
inversión y las políticas de lucha
contra el sida
en un penal del sureste de México a más
de 13 mil kilómetros de Qatar el balón
también Rueda entre los muros desde hace
casi dos décadas los internos realizan
su propio mundialito a la par de las
copas internacionales dentro de la
prisión el deporte se convierte en una
herramienta que les da disciplina
compañerismo y un aire de libertad
informe de Katia Espinoza
en este centro de readaptación social en
el sureste mexicano a más de 13.000
kilómetros de Qatar los internos juegan
su propia copa de la vida Miguel cumple
una condena de quince años y lleva Casi
11 años encerrado en prisión se ha
refugiado en el deporte para sentirse
libre
nada disciplina la verdad no olvido que
estoy que estoy preso estos 90 minutos
pues me
distraigo como si estuviera en otro
lugar pero en esta cárcel con más de
1.200 internos también hay otras
ocupaciones Además del fútbol que les
permiten su reinserción a la vida
productiva Cuando obtienen la libertad
para los reclusos es obligatorio
aprender algún oficio y si así lo desean
continuar con sus estudios incluyendo la
universidad y un máster
llevar a cabo Los pilares de la
reinserción la la educación la la salud
el deporte el trabajo Eso es lo que
nosotros este fomentamos y la la
comunicación la comunicación con ellos
el oficio escogido por Miguel fue la
carpintería que practica con pasión a la
par del deporte
también pues te da una constancia y una
pues así decirlo Este
vas agarrando un hábito no también y un
horario para trabajar y eso te hace pues
ser más responsable también
desde hace más de 20 años cada mundial
está estos internos la oportunidad de
sentir cada juego representando a los
equipos de la FIFA durante 28 Días tres
veces por semana porque esos 90 minutos
en la cancha se vive la fiebre del
mundial pero también el compañerismo la
disciplina el juego limpio y la libertad
de no ser juzgados más allá que por la
batalla en el terreno de juego
queremos agradecer al programa de
producción fotográfica por permitirnos
Grabar en lc y Bogotá y a ustedes
también Muchas gracias sigan con más
información en France 24 y France 24.com